just remind us of how you realize that
that something wasn't right with your
husband
um les
developed this smell when he was just
coming out for 32 and i kept saying to
him you're not showering properly and
he became quite angry about it at first
um but i decided well we have to live
with it that's it and didn't think much
of it and it would come and go but it
was getting stronger and stronger
and various other things
happened he was a bit more tired grumpy
and i thought he had a brain tumor so
when he was 44
he went to salford and uh was diagnosed
by uh aleister young
had you ever had you realized that that
you had this sort of olifactory sense
that you you could smell things that
perhaps other people couldn't
yes i did because my grandmother had it
it's it's hereditary
my two sisters have it as well
but they didn't do nursing um i nursed
at 72 i nursed in nightingale wards
beds close together open sputum mugs
metal bed pans that we had to wash so i
acquired this olfactory library
now what was the reaction of the medical
establishment to the fact that you you
said well you know i knew that he had
something wrong with him he smelled he
smelled different for 12 years
well i didn't go to the medical
fraternity um
les decided because he he was because he
had been a consultant anesthetist he
decided we had to find a researcher a
scientist
and dr tilo kunas at edinburgh
university was doing a lecture so i
turned up and i stood up at the end when
he asked for questions and i asked why
are you not using the smell of
parkinson's to diagnose it earlier um i
wish i'd had a camera to take a picture
of tilo's face because we're very good
friends now but he didn't understand
what i was asking he asked me to repeat
the question and he said oh well let's
speak about it afterwards but it was
quite a few months before he contacted
me again because he'd been at a dinner
and
this researcher in in cancer had said to
him look find that woman and he found me
through parkinson's uk
and
how have we now got from that point to
the point where there is actually now a
swab test that can be done
this is this is seven years now um i
have to
oh commend the the ban group at
manchester they've tested retested they
have done everything possible to make
sure it it has been in new swabs in a
freezer outside on a desk and they have
done every possibility and retested many
times to make sure that this is perfect
so now a machine is doing the job that
essentially your nasal passages have
been able to do all of this time and
your families also
what does this mean
yes
i hope it means that
parkinson's is now diagnosed with over
50 percent of neuronal damage i am very
much hoping that an early diagnosis can
prevent it getting to the neuronal
damage it will be diagnosed when the
constipation and loss of smell etc is
there and prevent the disease
progressing any further
so it could really help
the symptoms for those in the earlier
stages of parkinson and help ease the
rest of their time
yes very much so it would
i and that depends that we would like to
work with pharma as well to make sure
their
drugs work because we can measure the
volatiles as people are treated and so
yes and perdi is also professor pedita
barn is also looking at
the
progression
in uh parkinson's to see whether they
can measure it through this uh the
volatiles
it's a fantastic legacy uh joy joymel
lovely to talk to you and thanks a lot
for explaining a bit more about it today
thank you